- So,
how I wanted to talk to you
about science and life in science
was basically to try to
answer your questions,
not one by one but more like in bulk,
I organized it really
nicely, see in sessions,
and I'll try to answer
as many as possible.
So let's get started with,
I don't know, first I want to
show you how my place works
because somebody asked me how is my day
as a research associate in the lab.
So I come to work.
This is where I sit, and this is my view.
See, and my flowers.
- Beautiful.
- Flowers, I have a little
very short story about them.
When we locked down,
some people basically
never came back to the lab.
They just retired and they
left their flower pots.
And I was looking at them
throughout the summer,
and they were really not doing that great.
So I asked them if I can
just kind of adopt them.
So I adopted them and
I brought them to life.
So that's why I have so
many flower pots here
but it really makes me very happy.
I come in the morning, I flower the pots
and then answer emails.
That's the first thing I do,
although maybe I shouldn't,
but try to find my technician,
and we talk about what was
done in the previous days,
what needs to be done.
We look at the results.
Occasionally I do experiments by myself,
not as much anymore,
but when I was younger
I was doing experiments every day.
And some of them were just
experiments that I realized
that they have to do immediately,
and some are long-term experiments
that need a lot of planning.
And this is my bench, right?
It's actually rather long.
It should be, oh, this is my technician.
(indistinct)
(laughs)
And this is where we do work
that does not require
any special equipment
in terms of I dunno,
microscopes, PCR machines,
and so on and so forth.
For these, we have separate
rooms where we keep them
because they're kind of expensive and not,
I mean, they are not
like single use machine
because they are super expensive, right?
And when I was talking to your
teacher, Tracy, the other day
she really wanted me to show
you how the lab looks like.
And I tried to do that in person.
I did the test run and the
Wi-Fi is not good enough.
So what I would like to do
is to show you the movie that
I made a while ago of the lab
and it was for my son's class.
And while the movie's running
I will talk about each part of the lab.
Let me just see how I do that.
I share screen right?
- Yes, I made you cohost.
- Okay, share screen,
share desktop, and okay.
I need you guys to tell
me if you can see this.
- Yes.
- It's also very loud.
Let me see if I can kind of, okay.
So this is, you get out of the elevator
and this is in front of the lab.
You have to forgive me.
This was the kiddie movie.
So I thought that that
might be interesting
for them to see the plants.
It was 2013, we had a
lab meeting that day.
One person usually presents
a really big body of research
about once a year.
So this is what we called PCR room.
That's where we do
genotype (indistinct) mice
to see if they are appropriate genotype.
These are the shakers
where we grow bacteria,
and they work 24 hours.
They're really funny.
And the bacteria needs to be shaken
because of the oxygen and temperature.
So this is the lab.
One part of the lab with
refrigerators and benches.
Each person have one bench and a desk
which is usually close to it.
This is my part of the lab.
You can see the same view.
And it was early in the morning,
so there were no people, but
by the amount of crap on desks
and lab space benches
you can see that they was
really very busy at that time.
Liquid nitrogen.
We use that to freeze cells, tissues,
keep temperature super cool, low.
This is tissue culture room.
And (indistinct) because it needs to be,
everything in tissue
culture needs to be sterile.
You work in the hoods and
then you keep the cells
in these incubators at
a certain temperature
and CO2 and O2 levels.
Cryostat, this is the station
where we do radioactivity.
We don't do that anymore.
Not as much as we used to.
It's not necessary,
and it's very bothersome type
of filing reports and stuff
to actually be able to work
with radioactive things.
One of the offices.
This is a chemical code that
we use with really smelly
and dangerous reagents.
Glass washing area, where we
wash the dishes that we use.
Copy area, this is where we actually sit
and use these common computers
although each one of us
has its own.
Huh, this is a copy of a Nobel PriZe.
And to be honest with you
I never really understood
what it says here
but it lists people who got
the Novel Prize together
with the whole Greengard.
And this is the office.
We used to have a lot of people
who worked in the office,
business manager and two
secretaries, not anymore.
Kitchen, obviously very
important for coffee.
This is where we have our
meetings, lab meetings,
and we can also eat lunch there,
and, or we can have one-on-one meetings
when we need to discuss science.
And oh, I have to admit somebody.
- I admitted it, you're good to go.
- View on the other side of the building,
that's Roosevelt Thailand.
And as you can see,
this was before the
new building was built.
We could still see the highway.
And I think that we have
the other part of the lab
which is, coffee machine,
the most important thing.
Fuels us.
This is the letter for my
boss, from Bill Clinton
when he got the Nobel Prize.
I mean, not Bill Clinton, but my boss.
So Bill Clinton congratulated him.
And this is the other part of the lab.
I also have to say that
this is not a typical lab
because it's usually, biology
labs are life sciences labs
are usually smaller.
At the peak of of the lab
before Paul passed away,
we had about 50 people.
And now it's dwindled to,
I don't know maybe 15.
This is a sucrose preference test tubes.
This is my experiment from a while ago.
We still do that same type of experiment.
I'll talk about that shortly.
And this used to be my desk
and you don't care about this anymore.
Because this was again for
the kids and this is it.
That's how the lab looks like.
And then I also have few images
of the things that didn't
make it to the movie.
This is the cold room.
This is incredibly
important for every lab to,
I mean not necessarily cold room
but they have a cold space
where you can keep reagents
and do experiments that
need a cold temperature.
This is how it looks like inside.
This is where we keep different reagents
usually for cell culture,
but the others too.
And this door, this is not very common,
but I was always amazed by it.
This is actually the freezer.
And it's a room freezer where
the temperature is minus 20.
I really liked it a lot.
This is the place where I like to go
in the summer when it's really hot.
The first place that I
visit in the morning.
This is the electrophysiology rig
where electrophysiologist
can trace the signals
in one in neuron.
And this is actually
not, it's very common,
and it's very much in use still
but there are much newer
techniques that can trace activity
of many neurons at one time.
And these machines look
a little bit different.
We used to have two electrophysiologist
so that's another electrophysiology rig.
And this is yet another room.
This here is cryostat
where we cut frozen brains.
And then to either
immunohistochemistry or in C2
to detect different proteins
and RNase in brain tissue.
This machine is actually really cool.
You can isolate fluid from the brain
and then detect different type
of ions using this machine
and not only ions, but also
different neurotransmitters,
it's micro dialysis machine.
And this is confocal microscope.
The confocal microscope
can detect different fluorescent light.
And I think you can detect
as many as like six, eight at one time.
We usually do not more than four,
which means that on one brain section,
you can detect multiple proteins
if you use the antibodies that are tagged
with different fluorescent colors,
and you can do four or more at one time.
So we use all these
machines to study the brain
and the lab studies
three different diseases,
depression, Alzheimer's,
and Parkinson's disease.
And when I joined the lab, I
was actually kind of pushed
politely towards the Alzheimer's disease.
And I was thinking to myself, oh my God,
it's like you have to wait
for a year, year and a half
for things to finish,
and you can actually do your experiment.
And that was too long.
I was too impatient.
And I said, I'm gonna do more to disorders
because it's a much quicker result.
And I am actually now
having a really big project
on Alzheimer's disease.
And it's very interesting,
but for a while I've
been studying depression.
And the way that we approach that easily
we always either go top to
bottom or bottom to top,
and the bottom here being the genes,
and the top the behavior.
So there were a lot of questions here
about why we have chosen
the mouse as a model.
Well-
- Are you done sharing your screen?
- Oh, yes, sorry.
- So we can see you better.
- That's correct.
- Thank you.
- I should have stop share, huh, okay.
For now, maybe if we have time,
I'll show like one or two more movies,
but only if we have time.
So a lot of questions were about mice
and how similar are they to people,
and why did we choose mice?
A lot of it has to do with
being practical, right?
Yes, I understand the mouse.
Remember the thing that I
sent you, the little images?
And the mouse brain looks really smooth
and it's way smaller than the human brain.
But I have to tell you that
everything that human brain has
or let's say majority of
things that human brain has,
mouse brain has too.
It's just packed in much smaller space.
The cells are smaller.
The brain regions are smaller
but basic circuitry and
how neurons look like,
and how they're connected
together is basically the same.
Also the mechanism of how the
nerve impulse is generated.
It's also the same.
The speed might be different.
The external stimuli, the
response to environment
might be slightly different,
but in general, all of that
is more or less the same.
So that's why it is
perfectly fine to study
all sorts of different
diseases on mice first.
And then if you found a
different drug therapy target
or a different system or a gene
that is responsible for a disease
you can actually scale it
up to either bigger animals
which we don't really do that much anymore
or do clinical studies on people.
And there is also a few
other things about mice.
First, they reproduce very fast
and they develop very fast.
So the mouse is so-called adult
or rather young adult at six weeks.
And that makes it very fast
in terms of getting more
mice and getting the results,
the end result that you are looking for.
And they're also small
meaning they're cheap
to maintain in the lab.
They don't need a lot of space.
They don't need a lot of food.
And people who are
still working on monkeys
always say that it's much
better to study monkeys,
but I personally would not
be able to do any experiments
on monkeys because they're
such amazing animals,
and they remind me so much of little kids.
We actually have a
person that's Rockefeller
who works in monkeys,
and we can see them in
the animal facility,
and they're so much fun.
I don't know.
When you pass by the
door they look at you,
and they try to, I don't know.
They make some chirping sound.
It almost sounds like a bird chirping,
and they're really cute.
So I wouldn't be able to
do anything on monkeys.
And I think that there is also a law now
that forbid use of, let's say
chimps for animal research
unless, I think in some special
circumstances such as COVID.
Because I think that they tested
the first vaccines on chimps
although I'm not 100% sure.
But for that reason you
can still use chimps
which are 98% overlap,
gene overlap with people.
So they are incredibly similar to us.
But other than that, I don't really think
that a lot of neuroscience
is done on monkeys.
At least not neuroscience that I do.
And so there was also a question.
How do we approach depression in mice?
When you look at them and their behavior
you can actually see
that they exhibit similar behavior to us.
It's just that they can't talk, right.
But they're anxious.
You can clearly see that they are anxious.
If they are withdrawn
you can clearly see
that they are withdrawn.
If they are scared, you can
clearly see that they're scared
but this is science, right?
So we have to measure everything.
So there are a lot of behavioral tests
that are designed to
measure certain behaviors.
So for depression,
you know probably from, I
dunno just reading newspapers,
that there are the many
different types of symptoms
and each person doesn't
have all of the symptoms,
same as is with mice.
And somebody asked me
if there was something very
interesting that I found.
So for me, the very
interesting thing that I found
studying depression was
that you actually have mice
who are naturally depressed.
So when we get, let's say 40 mice
and you do a behavioral test
which is called social interaction,
mice are actually social animals.
So they like to interact with each other.
And they like to, it's same as with dogs.
When they see unknown dog on the street
they immediately run to it
and they sniff around
each other and so on.
So the mice do the same.
And you have this test
where you test the mice
with unknown possibly aggressive mice,
because they're way bigger than the mouse
that we are testing.
If they sniff around, and the
mouse is also in like a cage.
So it can't attack the other mouse.
If the mouse that we are testing
is spending a lot of time
around that unknown mouse,
we say that that's a normal behavior
because that's what they usually do,
and that, that mouse has a
normal social interaction.
However, you see mice
that are really super shy
and don't spend any time
around the other mouse.
So we always call them socially withdrawn,
which is one of the
symptoms of depression.
Tracy, what do you think?
Can I show them the, do we have time
for me to show them the actual test?
I have a movie, yes?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- We have until about 10 o'clock.
- So share screen again.
This is a PowerPoint, actually. (laughs)
- It's okay.
(indistinct)
- Finally I ended up on PowerPoint again.
- I just also wanna make sure
that there's some time for students
to actually share questions.
- Okay, so this is control
mouse, so-called normal,
and then look at them.
The unknown mouse is here in this tube.
Look how different they are.
This one goes in the
corner and just sits there.
Oops, I'm sorry.
I don't know what happened.
I did something strange.
And so this is one of the tests
that we use to detect depressive mice.
You got the point.
And then the mouse sat there
for another 10 minutes.
So we then look at the
genes in different cells
and try to figure out how each gene
that we find interesting
using bioinformatics methods.
We try to change the
expression of that gene
and see how that affects behavior again.
So we go again to the
behavior of the whole animal,
and what we found was
that, I mean, not only us
but other people too,
that depression actually
is something called polygenic disease.
So there is not one gene
that determines depression.
There is not one gene that
drives the Alzheimer's
or Parkinson's disease.
There are many genes, and
that's why it's incredibly hard
to A, find the reason of why
we develop these diseases,
and B, to find a really successful therapy
that can help very fast.
And for Parkinson's and Alzheimer's
we still didn't find any therapy.
So we are really trying
our best to work on that.
And I don't know, do
you have any questions
because I think that I'm kind
of done with the project.
I don't want to go to too much details
because I don't think
that this is the place
and time for it.
So do you have any other questions?
I'm looking at your questions right now
and see if I answered.
How do you measure brain activity?
So, as I said, brain activity
can be measured different ways
both by gene expression,
but also we can do the the rig thing,
the electrophysiology that I showed you.
- We have a hand up from Zoe.
So Zoe, I don't know if
you wanna unmute yourself
and go ahead and ask your question.
- [Zoe] Yeah, so you were talking
about how like you had the depressed mice,
but how do you make sure
that the mice that you get
and the mice that like
reproduce and make more mice
are actually depressed?
Like how do you control
for the fact that they might
not exhibit that specific gene?
- Okay, so that's the thing
that I didn't mention.
It's an excellent question
because it put me back to the
beginning of the research.
We actually modeled depression.
There are two ways to do this,
actually three ways to do it.
One way is to search for mice
that exhibit depression naturally
and then just inbreed them
over several generation
with other mice that also
show depressive phenotype.
And that way you get
actually an inbred strain
which exhibits some
symptoms of depression.
We don't do that in the lab.
We do two different approaches.
One is to make a transgenic mouse
which has genes that are changed.
And we already know that
this gene affects depression,
so we change the gene and
make a transgenic mouse,
and that's called either
knock out or knock in mice.
So there are genetic models
but it's only one gene that it is changed.
And then the third thing
which is what I do is we model depression.
There are definitely many different types
of models for depression.
We usually expose so-called
normal wild-type mice
to some harsh things.
And that's why I'm not
gonna show you any movies,
such as social defeat
where one aggressive mouse
attacks another mouse.
And we repeat that day
after day for 10 days
for about a few minutes each day.
And finally the mice
become pretty depressed.
There is also something
called restraint stress
where you put them in
a really small tubes.
So they can't move.
There is social isolation
test where you keep mice
one per cage.
As I said, there are social animals,
so they like to be with other mice,
and being alone in the cage
makes them incredibly depressed.
So this is how we take these mice then
and study their gene expression.
So we actually really do
know and confirm by tests
that we are working on a depressive mouse.
And then we also have a control group
which are just normal, wild type mice
that were not exposed to
this harsh environment.
And we compare them between each other
doing all sorts of different tests.
Does that answer your question?
Okay, so somebody actually
asked if we are ready to go
from a mouse brain to a
human brain as a next step
in my project.
Unfortunately I am not.
Although in my project,
I found that Statins
which are usually taken for cholesterol,
actually have a really pretty good effect
on one specific gene and
what it does in the brain
in terms of depression.
So what I would like to do in
the future is to study people
who take Statins
and then for either heart
disease or cholesterol
and see how prevalent
these depressive phenotype
in these people, and then see
that if maybe a different dose
of Statins can be added
to other antidepressants
to help people who have depression
especially if it's connected
to a stressful life.
So that was kind of
another interesting thing
that came out of my study.
I can't publish that, obviously
because I don't have any people's data
but I think that would be a nice next step
to actually really work
towards helping people with depression.
Okay, there are some other
really interesting questions
about, not really
connected to my research,
but more more of the life I've chosen.
Why did I choose to be neuroscientist?
And do I have any advice?
So maybe I should answer
and talk a little bit about that, right?
So I basically never did
anything else, but neuroscience
except my undergrad.
My undergrad was molecular biology
and only one part like maybe
one course was neuroscience.
And it was actually not my
favorite course by all means.
I didn't like the professor
either, unfortunately.
And after I finished college
I wanted to go to graduate
school immediately.
And the only place where they actually,
they had immediate opening
was the neuroscience program.
And I said, well, why not?
I can give it a try and slowly over.
Let's say like two years, I got into it,
and then really fell in love with it.
So it was not the love on first sight.
And this is my, I think best advice
for anybody try different things.
If you don't like something,
but you think that there is
a nice opportunity for you,
just stick around a little while longer
and see if you like it.
Don't just drop things immediately.
If you don't like it in
terms of science obviously,
I can't talk about
other other professions.
And then the other thing that
is also incredibly important
in science is that you
don't get results fast.
I mean it's very rarely that
things work from the first go.
And you have to just kind
of be incredibly patient.
And I think the endurance and perseverance
are incredibly important
for the scientist.
And one of my advisors also told me
that to be a good
scientist you need actually
to deal with backseats pretty well,
because there are a lot
of them along the line
but then the reward when
things actually work
when you get good
results are so rewarding.
And so it makes you so happy
that it's actually worth doing it.
And in terms of neuroscience,
I think it's actually really,
really nice field to go to
because there are so many different things
and you don't actually have
to study only the brain.
There are other parts of neurosciences
that are incredibly important
such as spinal cord injury.
And I don't know, even
heart disease and gut
is incredibly hot topic right now
because all of them need
brain and nerve cells
to function properly.
So that connection between
the heart and the guts
with the brain is not necessarily
hardcore neuroscience,
but also incredibly important
and interesting field.
Cancers of the brain
are pretty devastating.
And a lot of them with one
exception of medulla blastoma
are pretty deadly, and they
are not easily treated.
So that's another really
interesting field to go to.
And then there is always basic
science that you can work on.
So I think that there
is a lot of potential
in neuroscience field and also
connection with psychology,
with economics but that's
actually not my cup of tea
because I really never did any of that.
And I find it difficult
to read these papers
because I don't understand the fine point.
I understand the abstract,
and then after that, not so much,
maybe the first paragraph
for the introduction,
but other than that,
summary is the only thing
that I understand.
But that's actually really
kind of cool fields.
So, and there was a person Cedic,
that asked me about
something very specific.
So this is why I like to do
these kinds of presentations
because all your questions
force me to actually rethink
why am I doing things.
So he asked, or she, I am sorry.
I actually, I'm not sure
if it's a she or he.
What do I think about Neuralink?
I have to admit, I
didn't know what that is.
So I Googled it and I actually,
the therapy itself it's
known for a really long time.
This is I think, just
the company that does it.
One of the companies that does it.
You put the electrodes in
different brain regions,
and by activating these electrodes,
you can actually turn on and
off and manipulate things
around the house
that I guess have some
sort of Wi-Fi connection.
So you will think about
turning on the light
and the light turns on.
And I honestly, it gave me creeps
because it sounded like
a science fiction movie,
and I immediately could see all sorts
of bad things that can happen with it.
But on the other hand
it's been done for Parkinson's disease
and treatment resistant
depression for quite a while now.
They put a little electrodes
in for depression area 25,
Brodmann area 25, which is
somewhere here, deep down,
and then for the Parkinson's
disease in substantia nigra
which is somewhere here deep down
to basically activate that area
because the activity of
neurons itself is not adequate
to help people A, overcome
their depressive phase,
and for Parkinson's to actually move
and apparently it works.
I mean, for Parkinson's
I saw in the movies
it's amazing when you turn on
the electrode in the brain,
the person who was really rigid
and could not move at all,
all of a sudden starts talking and moving.
And it's amazing what it can do.
So I think that in that sense,
Neuralink is actually
really good but it would be,
and it is really great for a
very limited type of disease,
such as Parkinson's
disease, maybe depression.
It would not probably
be able to help people
with multiple sclerosis, Alzheimer's.
It would be actually great for people
who have spinal cord injuries.
So for example, people who are
paraplegic, and cannot move,
I think that it would be
absolutely great for them
because it could allow them to move again.
Can you imagine that?
It would be amazing.
So I am all for it, but on the other hand,
I'm a little uneasy because just,
I don't know thinking about
you want to, I don't know,
create somebody or turn on
something that you should not,
and you're actually able doing that
with a little electrode in
your brain gives me creeps.
I don't know.
What do you think?
You can maybe discuss
that with Tracy, later?
It's another topic,
it's ethics in science.
And I think everybody
has to have that kind of really frank talk
at all different times in
your learning experience
in school, in college, in graduate school.
I think that we need more ethical classes.
So we actually know what
we're doing and why.
Okay, does anybody, did I
answer all of your questions
more or less?
Something really, what is
the most challenging part
of my research?
Writing the paper. (laughs)
The (indistinct) we're
done doing right now.
You really need to actually write well.
So for all your budding scientists there,
don't discard your literature
classes and reading books
because in writing, because
you are going to need that
no matter what.
If you'll choose science,
and you'll go to work
in any kind of science,
you do need to actually
compose your thoughts
and to be able to put that
on the paper successfully.
So other people are
really eager to read it
and understand what's the message
that you're trying to convey.
So for me that's hard.
Not only because English
is my second language
but I think that I have
difficulties writing in Serbian too.
So that's hard.
And the other hard thing
is when things don't work,
then you have to
troubleshoot to figure out
why are they not working
to actually maybe even
because if you're not
getting a result, that's bad
but if you are getting
the different results
than what you expected,
you really have kind of switch very fast
and have a different overview
because you need to explain
why did you get the different results.
So you have to switch
back and forth between.
You can't basically rely on the thing
on your hypothesis as set in
stone, you have to be flexible.
So that's also not always easy.
And oh, I like this question.
Was there ever a time when you got stuck
and had to start all over again?
Man, so many times. (laughs)
And don't be, I don't know.
I think that it happens to everybody,
and not only in science,
but in other professions.
You just have to be very persistent.
And in my what, 30 years
of science research,
I changed fields.
I mean, it was always neuroscience,
but I've changed the topic several times.
And actually most of the time
was because I kind of thought
that the new field would be
very interesting to study
and to learn something new.
So that's it.
Just continue.